f of X is equal to 7x minus 5 G of X is
equal to X to the third power plus 4x
and then they asked us to find F times G
of X so the first thing to realize that
this notation F times G of X it's just
referring to a function that is a
product of f of X and G of X so by
definition this notation just means f of
X f of X x times G of X and then we just
have to substitute f of X with this
definition G of X with this definition
and then multiply out these algebraic
expressions so f of X is right over
there and G of X G of X is right over
there so let's do it
so this is going to be equal to switch
back to the orange color it's going to
be equal to f of X which is 7x minus 5
times G of X and G of X is X to the
third power plus 4 X X to the third
power plus 4 X and you could we're
multiplying to two expressions that each
have two terms you could use foil if you
like I don't like using foil because you
might forget what it's even about this
is really oil is really just multiple
using the distributive property twice so
for example you take this expression
whatever you have out here if you had a
nine out here or an A or an X or
anything now you have 7x minus 5 if
you're multiplying it times this
expression you would multiply this times
each term over here so when you multiply
7x minus 5 times X to the third you get
and I'll write it this way you get X to
the third times actually let me write it
the other way you get 7x minus 5 times X
to the third times X to the third and
then you have plus 7x minus 5 plus 7x
minus 5 times 4x times 4x and now we can
do this derivative property again we're
not normally used to seeing the things
we distribute on the right hand side was
the same exact idea we could put the X
to the third here as well and when we
distribute you multiply x to the third
times 7x
at times negative 5 X to the 3rd times 7
X is 7 X 7 X to the 4th power X to the
3rd times negative 5 is minus 5 X to the
3rd and then you do it over here you
distribute the 4 X tie over the 7 X or
4x times 7x is plus 28 x squared 4x
times negative 5 is minus minus 20x
and let's see if we can simplify this we
only have one fourth degree term one
third-degree term one second-degree term
and one first degree term so actually
you can't simplify this anymore and
we're done this is the product of those
two function definitions this is f times
G of X it is a new function created by
multiplying the other two functions